so as they're coming in you hear these
cheetah cub chirps echoing through the
courtroom
in the late afternoon of a hot day in
hargesa the capital of somaliland
national geographic animals editor
rachel bale sat in on an unusual trial
was the proceeding in somali in the
somali language
yes the proceeding was entirely in
somali so i had my translator sitting
next to me whispering in my ear all of
the translations the entire time
so this was the trial of abdi haiwan
aka animal abdi a notorious cheetah
smuggler
and the man himself was held in a small
metal cell near the somaliland judge
yeah it's a prison cell with metal bars
so that's where the defendants sit
they're locked back there there's a
bench in there for them to sit
and when they address the court they
stand up they walk to the bars
and they talk to the lawyer the judge
ten cheetah cubs taken from the wild had
been found in the home of abdi haiwan's
accomplice
half of those cubs were brought in as a
key piece of evidence in the case
and after the judge came in and sat down
from the back of the courtroom
a guy walks in with
a big pet carrier
and five cheetah cubs in it
you can hear them
chirping
these cubs now live in a rescue center
with around 60 more cheetahs recovered
from other trafficking operations
and that's where they'll spend the rest
of their lives and then the cubs were
brought over to the cell
and held up to the bars of the cell for
abdi haiwan and his co-defendant to take
a look at
they were asked to identify them if they
recognized the cats or not did he claim
ownership of these
abdi haiwan did not claim ownership of
the cubs he kind of glanced sideways at
them
shrugged his shoulders and said i've
never seen them before
once a cheetah cub has been taken from
its mother it can never survive in the
wild again
because it never learned to hunt
and so it'll have to spend the rest of
its life in some type of captivity
think about that for a minute this is
the world's fastest land animal and it
can hit speeds of up to 70 miles per
hour on the open plain
but these cheetahs will never get to run
that fast more importantly though
they won't contribute to the dwindling
wild population
these cheetahs can't go free
but abi hai one might
[Music]
i'm peter guinn editor-at-large at
national geographic and you're listening
to overheard a show where we eavesdrop
on the wild conversations we have here
at natgeo and follow them to the edges
of our big weird beautiful world
this week we're following the chain of
cheetah trafficking from the capture of
wild cheetahs in the horn of africa to
the coast of somaliland
it's a trade route thousands of years
old that's used for all kinds of illegal
smuggling
but the people of somaliland just might
be able to block it
more after this
compared to other wildlife trafficking
the trade in cheetahs is relatively
small
estimated to be a few hundred per year
but there aren't many cheetahs in the
wild to begin with so how are cheetahs
doing overall right now in the world
so overall cheetahs are not doing well
this is sarah durant she's a national
geographic explorer and director of
science at the zoological society of
london and she runs the world's longest
continuous study of wild cheetahs
there's only around about 7 000 of them
left globally
which is it's tiny it's a tiny number of
animals and that tiny number of animals
is spread across around about three
million square kilometers
how would that compare to something like
lions or tigers or you know other other
cat species that people are pretty
familiar with
so
compared to um lions and their
population is is around about 30 000 or
so and at the same time if you look at
the protected areas so if you look at
serengeti for example it can support
about about 3 000 lines but it can only
support around about 300 cheetahs
wow the whole serengeti can only support
about 300 cheetahs
yeah oh my gosh that's amazing
wow so and the reason they're at such
low densities compared to these other
predators is because
they they
they have a strategy of avoidance
okay so once on a trip in the serengeti
i actually got to see a cheetah kill a
thompson's gazelle the cat went from a
near standstill to a blur on the
savannah
they really are the hot rods of the
animal kingdom
but cheetahs can't really defend their
kills from other big carnivores like
lions or hyenas
and sure enough the lion showed up and
chased the cheetah off kind of like a
schoolyard bully taking a kid's lunch
money
sarah explained my cat was probably
young because mature cheetahs generally
avoid hunting when lions are around
that's been the key to how they managed
to co-exist with these predators for for
millennia
but now it's becoming a problem because
there's nowhere left for them to move to
the species low density means that
losing even a few cheetahs is a big blow
to the individual groups
if you think of a cheetah population
which we think in ethiopia is around
about 200 300 cheetahs
you could think if you had 20 30
cheetahs going out
every year that would have a massive
impact on that population and we think
it's much higher than that
cheetahs smuggled from all over east
africa tend to pass through one place
somaliland
rachel bail again somaliland is the
epicenter of the cheetah trade
and in large part that's because of its
geography
i'm going gonna ask you to play a little
mental geography
picture the place on a world map where
the northeast part of africa swoops
under the arabian peninsula
okay you got it
at the tip of the peninsula is yemen
facing it is the horn of africa which
juts out into the indian ocean
that's where somaliland is
it's just a few hours by boat away from
the vast and sparsely settled yemeni
coastline and the rest of the middle
east beyond
that makes it ideal for smugglers trying
to get cheetahs to buyers in the middle
east
somaliland is pretty large somewhere
between the size of florida and missouri
but you'd be hard-pressed to find it on
a standard political map
that's because the international
community still sees it as part of
somalia not as an independent country
every country in the world still
considers somaliland part of somalia
even though somaliland has its own
democratic government
they have their own coast guard and army
their own judicial system and laws it
functions entirely independently and
far more successfully than somalia in
fact it's
one of the more well-functioning
democracies in africa period
somaliland has a complicated history
it was once controlled by the british
while the rest of somalia was an italian
colony the two merged into one
independent country in 1960
but somaliland broke away from somalia
30 years ago after a violent civil war
it's been functioning as an independent
state ever since but it's not officially
recognized by the international
community
does that play any role in the cheetah
trafficking story it's made it a lot
harder for somaliland to get the
international aid
it needs and wants to fight cheetah
trafficking
because somaliland isn't recognized as
independent on the international stage
somaliland doesn't have access to most
of the funding it needs to be able to
fight the cheetah trade while this lack
of recognition makes things more
difficult rachel thinks that it's also
helping to motivate their efforts to
stop trafficking and it seems to me that
one of the ways they're trying to
demonstrate that they have a functional
government subject to the rule of law is
by really cracking down on trafficking
of all kinds
and
by
focusing on
wildlife it's just another way for
somaliland to say like
hey look world we're paying attention
not only to economic development and our
citizens and good governance but also to
the environment
it also helps that the minister of the
environment
minister shukri
is just personally extremely passionate
about about stopping cheetah trafficking
she's the one who really
made it a national issue because she
cares so much about it um yes i've been
a minister for
seven years and a half now
when rachel was covering the trial in
the capital she recorded this interview
with minister shukri [ __ ] ismail
muhammad
and the minister told rachel that in her
first week on the job
five confiscated cheetah cubs actually
died of malnutrition in her office
building
five cheetahs died in here yeah that was
my first week as a minister
and i said why
why are we why are people taking the
cheaters from the wine and they said
what they are selling selling
they are not goats they are not ships
they are not
why are they selling the cheaters
minister shukri says that many of the
somalilanders who come across wild
cheetahs see selling the cubs as a way
to make additional money especially if
the cheetah mother had killed one of
their goats which is what happened to
mati ferrar duksie
so mati is a nomadic pastoralist living
in western somaliland
and
pastoralism is the dominant way of life
for most people
across the region this is nicole sobeki
the photographer who went with rachel to
interview mati
a series of recent droughts in
somaliland has made keeping large herds
of animals much more difficult for the
people living there
so his father had 500 sheep and goats
mahdi is 40.
and that's really not enough to sustain
his family of one wife and seven kids
and so he's really struggling they're
living on the razor's edge of survival
and so
for his father when a cheetah took one
of his goats it wasn't a big deal he was
able to just brush it off and move on
with makti that's you know that could
mean the difference between being able
to feed his family or not
mati's father might have been able to
brush off the occasional cheetah attack
but when he caught a cheetah eating a
goat and not just any goat but one that
his own son was relying on for milk
he felt he had to do something
i felt so bitter
i nearly cried
but and then i decided to to revenge on
and definitely shoot it
i rushed for my gun
he talked about kissing his gun after
that and
you know
feeling
vindicated feeling revenge
that he had been able to
you know
kill the cheetah that had killed the
goat that his young son had been relying
on
and
that was you know in his minds not only
justified but the right thing to do
but the cheetah carcass was discovered
and mahdi was arrested after that the
body was pulled
to the road
i was arrested
and
despite
me not knowing
that there was an organization or
minister that was protecting it
getting the word out to nomadic farmers
is part of the challenge of cheetah
conservation in this area
mati didn't know that cheetahs were
endangered or that it was illegal to
hunt them so he was let off with a
warning and he promised not to harm
cheetahs in the future
since makti promised not to kill any
more cheetah he has actually suffered
several losses of goats
but he has
stayed firm to his promise and
he has convinced other
friends of his to call in and to work to
release
cheetah that they have taken from the
wilds
but the choice between conservation and
illegal commerce isn't always easy
in a reporting rachel found that
powerful incentives to sell cheetah cubs
remain
when
a cheetah kills
a goat
and you only have 50 goats that is a
huge blow to your income
and you need to try to recoup that loss
all pastoralists know there's a market
for cheetah cubs they know there's
somebody who's gonna pay money for those
cheetah cups who's buying the cheetahs
so um
it's people who own private menageries
of all kinds of animals
um think about like
a wealthy saudi prince or somebody in
dubai who has
you know a cheetah some lions uh some
ocelots
maybe a monkey
you know it becomes part of a collection
interesting
so
what are they doing with the cheetah
that's a really good question
so cheetahs are
in between big cats and small cats
because they're not
so big
and
they're not particularly aggressive at
least in comparison to a lion or a tiger
you know people will bring them into
their house you have there are pictures
on instagram of people lounging in their
living rooms watching tv with their
cheetahs
cheetahs have a long history as exotic
pets they've been kept by egyptian
pharaohs renaissance nobles and more
recently instagram influencers social
media definitely drives the trade
particularly instagram you get people
who have public accounts you know tens
of thousands of followers who post
pictures of them and their pet cheetahs
and it's
in many ways a sign of
not just wealth but of privilege and
influence because
in most places in these gulf countries
it is illegal to own a pet cheetah
um or any big cat
so by posting openly that you have one
is sort of like saying
look how important i am this is illegal
but i still have it
so
since instagram you mentioned
specifically instagram but since
instagram is such a driver for this
illegal market
have they you know what's there been
their response to this instagram has not
responded to my questions or requests
for comment
in theory
you know illegal activity isn't supposed
to happen on the platform and instagram
isn't just a place where people show off
their pet cheetahs it's also a place
where people sell and buy pet cheetahs
so those ads are
against their policy
but as we've seen with social media
platforms not just instagram all social
media platforms
you know you get a little creative and
it's easy enough to get around those
restrictions
but someone needs to connect the farmers
who might happen across wild cheetah
cubs to the people who might want to buy
them as pets
and that brings us back to abdi haiwan
and the trial in the somaliland
courtroom
we spent 10 days traveling throughout
western somaliland
every single person i talked to whether
they were
a fisherman in a beach community or like
a driver local cot seller where law
enforcement had heard of this guy really
oh my gosh he's that notorious
so notorious
yeah it was um
it was frankly amazing
nobody would mention him
right away when we started talking about
cheetah trafficking but halfway through
the interview and i'd be like so have
you heard of this guy abdi haiwan it was
oh yeah yeah he's the worst of them all
he's the one who's making cheetahs
extinct in the region is what one guy
told me
catching abdi haiwan was a huge priority
for the smaller land authorities one
coast guard unit painted his name
outside their building as a reminder
that he was still at large
abdi haiwan himself is a bit of a
mystery i think he's about 40 years old
again this is being pieced together by
multiple
sources who know different pieces of the
story and have slightly varying stories
but it sounds like abdijuan got his
start working for another cheetah
trafficking network
he had begun as a lower level guy
definitely not the top of the chain
doing the grunt work um stuff like that
and he's
as we've learned extremely resourceful
and charismatic he knows how to get what
he wants and build a network so he
started building his own network
he made direct connections with buyers
in the gulf
and essentially
overtook the syndicate he was working
for
in that way he managed to build up his
own massive network that now seems to be
the top network supplying cheetah cubs
out of the horn of africa
and he'd finally been caught again
and rachel and nicole the photographer
were there for the last day of his trial
in hargesa
in a quiet moment before the judge
arrived nicole took his picture
rachel never got to interview him but
she got a snapshot of her own every
person i interviewed i said tell me what
abdi haiwan is like
totally open-ended question
and i posed this question both to you
know his opponents like
the police and military but also to
people
he's worked with like the middlemen who
helped broker sales
or to
you know fishermen in a village who have
benefited from his
generosity i.e
payments to keep their mouths shut
um
and everybody just about described him
the same way that's
cold-blooded charismatic and
having a hard heart
i wanted to find that sympathetic angle
and i haven't been able to yet
in the courtroom abdi haiwan claimed
he'd never seen those five cheetah cups
before
but that was difficult to believe when
the prosecutor brought out abdi hawan's
cell phone
it was filled with pictures of cubs and
voice messages negotiating what he
wanted in return for them
rachel says he seemed unconcerned about
this evidence
so
the trial ended with
him
giving his closing argument because he
was representing himself so he walked up
to the bars of the cell faced the judge
and made his final argument which was
essentially
i'm not guilty these were the other guys
cubs i don't know
don't blame me
the end
he was very casual very confident
and that was it the case was closed the
judge excused everybody
and we all left to wait for the verdict
so rachel came home and began writing
the story not knowing what would happen
next
for the next couple weeks i was
constantly checking my whatsapp to see
if anybody in somaliland had texted me
updates from the case
and all of a sudden i got a link to a
press release that um said he was found
guilty and he was given
the longest ever sentence in somaliland
for an environmental crime
it was very exciting it was a big
landmark everybody was was celebrating
abdi hawan was sentenced to four years
in prison
and it seems to have made a difference
from what i've heard cheetah smuggling
in western somaliland has dropped off a
lot since his arrest
but that conviction might not stick
he was granted an appeal and is awaiting
a new trial leaving the possibility that
his conviction could be overturned
as notorious as abdi hai one is though
this problem isn't just about one
cheetah smuggler
somaliland's environmental minister is
looking at the bigger picture
we are a country that don't want to see
wildlife suffering on wildlife trade
minister shukri is working to educate a
new generation of somalilanders about
taking care of the region's wild
cheetahs
her office teamed up with a non-profit
called the cheetah conservation fund to
help with public outreach
rachel got to visit a classroom of 10
year olds where a guest speaker
explained the cheetah's role in the
environment
and what the students should do when
they saw one even when it was
threatening their family's livestock yes
i'm soon ending would you like to see
more no we have to finish should we go
to class
somaliland used to have
lots of cheetahs leopards elephants
giraffes
animals that are nowhere near the area
anymore and even right now
nobody has any idea how many cheetahs
are in somaliland
and being able to protect it and even
help bring them back
would be
such a win both i think for somalilands
pride and for recognition on the
international stage
and because of all this
there's a chance that when these kids
grow up
their kids will have a chance to see a
wild cheetah
to see nicole's pictures and read
rachel's reporting check out their
article cheetahs for sale we've included
a link to their story in our show notes
we're also including links to a few
other resources including a short video
about the basics of cheetah biology and
conservation
as well as an article about how drought
is affecting somaliland
meanwhile on the other end of the
continent i'd like to share another
podcast in the national geographic
family guardians of the river produced
by explorer catherine de medici jaffe
the eight episode series follows
scientists and members of the local
community as they strive to protect the
okavango river system in southern africa
all this and more can be found in our
show notes they're right there in your
podcast app
and while you're there be sure to rate
and review us in apple podcasts it
really helps our listeners find us
[Music]
overheard at national geographic is
produced by brian gutierrez jacob pinter
laura soom and alana strauss
our senior editor is eli chen
our senior producer is carlo wills our
executive producer of audio's d'var
artelon
our fact checkers are robin palmer and
julie beer
our copy editor is amy kozak
hansdale sue sound designed this episode
and composed our theme music
this podcast is a production of national
geographic partners
the national geographic society
committed to illuminating and protecting
the wonder of our world funds the work
of national geographic explorer sarah
durant
whitney johnson is the director of
visuals and immersive experiences
susan goldberg is national geographic's
editorial director
and i'm your host peter gwynne thanks
for listening and see all next time
[Music]
you